Yeah.
See,
Starbucks is way up the chart.
Look at that there.
Starbucks tall is like closing in on 200 and what does it looks like about two
70 yeah,
somewhere in the range of 270 milligrams caffeine.
But that's a coffee.
That's not right.
Espresso coffee.
It would be better to go to Starbucks and get a tall coffee that,
but there's an espresso.
See how low it is?
It's below a hundred.
So that's why I'm drinking so many.
So when I drank five,
I guess,
I think I had five,
I think 500 milligrams,
which is basically less than drinking two of these things.
See?
Yeah.
These Caveman Nitros.
These are the shit.
Yeah,
I live off these goddamn things.
They're responsible for half my productivity.
Uh,
basically I'm too chicken shit to go on Adderall.
So I just,
I just drink this stuff all day.
Good move.
I,
there's nothing wrong with coffee,
man.
Scared of Adderall.
But people admit they're alert,
they're addicted to coffee and everyone's like,
God,
me too.
If you go,
dude,
I am so addicted to Adderall,
they'll let go.
Katie Jo,
not calling you to like,
you're going to think I'm laying,
but til five years ago I didn't even know what Adderall,
it was good.
No,
I think you're smart.
I like all my friends in Houston.
They do it and I asked my friend,
like I texted him and I go,
hey man,
you got a,
what's your addie?
And he goes,
yeah,
we got Adderall.
I was like,
what are you know your address to go to your house?
Like literally he thought it was talking about Adderall and then he explained to
me like when you're in a club and you want to stay up and you want to stay like
energize you take Adderall.
And I was like,
oh,
okay.
But I,
I don't drink so I can stay up till three,
four o'clock in the morning,
I'd be fine.
What's fascinating about Adderall is what they've essentially done is taken an
amphetamine and made it so that if you prescribe it for a condition,
right?
Like they give it to people who have what add is one of them,
write whatever the fuck that means.
And it's very debatable whether or not you have it or don't have.
Everybody has a B.
Dot.
I have it for sure if it's real,
if it's real,
I have it.
But they give you Adderall,
which is fucking speed.
And because it's a medication that you give to somebody who has supposedly has a
condition.
And by the way,
I'm not diagnosing you.
If you're out there,
you're getting frustrated with me right now.
Just listen to me.
It's fucking speed.
Maybe you need speed.
Maybe you're that person that needs speed.
Maybe you do need it legitimately as a medication,
but there's a fuck load of people that are just doing speed.
So by somebody giving you speed,
it's supposed to slow you down.
So you want to have add,
is that the reason they say legit?
If you have the legit add,
look,
I am not doubting that some people have what a hundred sky have worse than I
have.
There's a spectrum,
right,
with everything.
But for some people,
when they take Adderall or similar type of substances,
it actually lets them focus and they can,
they can actually be on track.
So by speeding it up,
somehow it focuses at it.
I think it's,
I think the idea is that it's proof that their system is wired wrong,
which is why when you give them that speed,
they can send her out and mellow out.